usemos la teoría de repulsión de pares
de electrones de valencia de sfr por sus
siglas en inglés también conocida como
er p esp
cr pv para predecir la geometría de la
molécula de penta cloruro de fósforo lo
primero que necesitamos es dibujar
nuestra estructura de puntos de louis
para mostrar nuestros electrones de
valencia entonces sabemos que el fósforo
se encuentra en el grupo 5 de la tabla
periódica así que tiene 5 electrones de
valencia y el cloro se encuentra en el
grupo 7 pero como tenemos 5 átomos de
cloro 7 por 5 es igual a 35 más 5
tenemos 40 electrones de valencia en
total que colocaremos en nuestra
estructura
el fósforo es nuestro átomo central
porque no es tan electro negativo como
el cloro y está unido a 5 átomos de
cloro
contemos cuántos electrones ya tenemos
hasta ahora aquí tenemos 2 4 6 8 10
entonces 40 menos 10 nos falta colocar
30 electrones de valencia y los podemos
poner en nuestros átomos terminales los
flores para que completen su octeto como
cada cloro ya tiene 12 electrones de
valencia a su alrededor
podemos agregar 6 electrones
cada cloro queda rodeado de 8 electrones
entonces si agregamos 6 electrones a 5
átomos de cloro 6 por 5 es igual a 30 ya
colocamos todos los electrones de
valencia y observen que el fósforo ha
excedido la regla del octeto está
rodeado por 10 electrones de valencia
pero no hay problema porque el fósforo
se encuentra en el periodo 3 de la tabla
periódica y si calculamos la carga
formal del fósforo encontraremos que es
igual a cero entonces esta es nuestra
estructura y en el paso 2 hay que contar
el número de nubes electrónicas que hay
alrededor del átomo central recordemos
que una nube electrónica es una región
de densidad electrónica y podemos decir
que estos enlaces son regiones de
densidad electrónica estos enlaces
son nubes electrónicas forman una
geometría y pirámide trígono trataré de
dibujar le tenemos al fósforo en el
centro y después tenemos tres átomos de
cloro en el mismo plano estas son las
posiciones ecuatoriales porque se
encuentran paralelas al ecuador entonces
tenemos tres átomos de cloro en el mismo
plano y después tenemos un cloro por
arriba del plan y un cloro por abajo del
plan estas son las posiciones axiales
voy a tratar de mostrarles cómo es la
geometría y pirámide tribunal tenemos
una pirámide hacia arriba
y tenemos otra pirámide hacia abajo
esta es la geometría de pirámide three
gonna be pirámide
trigo
ahora vamos a enfocarnos en estos tres
claros que se encuentran en el mismo
plano observen que estos vértices
corresponden a cada uno de esos átomos
están en el mismo plano entonces estos
son los claros ecuatoriales y si
queremos saber el ángulo de enlace entre
estos claros cuando vimos la geometría
tribunal plana dijimos que para saber el
ángulo sólo había que dividir 360 entre
tres así que el ángulo de enlace para
este caso es de 120 grados y si nos
enfocamos en los claros que están en la
posición axial estos dos observen que
corresponden a estos vértices en nuestra
geometría vy pirámide trigon al y si
dibujamos una línea que los conecte
observen que se encuentran a 180 grados
así que tenemos un ángulo de enlace
180 grados entre estos claros y
finalmente el ángulo de enlace entre el
cloro axial de arriba y algunos de los
claros verdes es de 90 grados este
ángulo de enlace es de 90 grados así que
tenemos tres ángulos de enlace en la
geometría vi pirámide trigo nal y es muy
importante que entendamos esta geometría
porque todas las estructuras con cinco
nubes electrónicas adoptarán esta
geometría por eso es muy importante
conocer esas posiciones en el cuarto
paso hay que ignorar cualquier par de
electrones libres para predecir la
geometría de la molécula pero como no
tenemos pares de electrones libres en
nuestro átomo central
la molécula tiene la misma geometría de
las nubes electrónicas de pirámide
trigon al hagamos otro ejemplo
ahora tenemos detrás fluoruro de azufre
vamos a contar nuestros electrones de
valencia el azufre se encuentra en el
grupo 6 tiene 6 electrones de valencia y
el flúor tiene 7 electrones de valencia
pero como tenemos 4 átomos de flúor 7
por 4 es igual a 28 y 28 6 es igual a 34
electrones de valencia en total que
colocaremos en nuestra estructura ahora
el azufre es nuestro átomo central
porque el flúor es más electro negativo
entonces tenemos al azufre que está
unido a 4 átomos de flúor
y ahí está y ya tenemos 2 468 electrones
de valencia entonces 34 menos 8 nos
faltan 26 electrones de valencia por
colocar y podemos empezar con nuestros
átomos terminales los átomos de flúor
recordemos que al flúor le gusta tener
su octeto así que agregamos 6 electrones
de valencia a cada uno de los 4 átomos
de flúor
entonces 6 por 4 es igual a 24 y 26
menos 24 aún nos faltan 2 electrones de
valencia hay que colocarlos en el átomo
central así que tenemos un par de
electrones libres en nuestro azufre y
observen que al agregar ese par de
electrones libres el azufre excede la
regla del octeto pero no hay problema
porque el azufre se encuentra en el
periodo 3 de la tabla periódica tiene
espacio en su última capa electrónica y
si calculamos la carga formal
encontraremos que el azufre tiene una
carga formal igual a 0 regresemos a
nuestros pasos después del paso 1 el
siguiente paso es contar el número de
nubes electrónicas que tenemos alrededor
del átomo central entonces busquemos las
regiones de densidad electrónica
alrededor de nuestro átomo
como por ejemplo estos enlaces ésta es
una nube electrónica por acá tenemos
otra esta es otra también esta y este
par de electrones libres en el azufre
también es una nube electrónica así que
tenemos sin con nubes electrónicas como
en el ejemplo anterior y por lo tanto
adoptan una geometría de pirámide
trígono pero vamos a dibujar dos
posibles versiones para esta molécula en
la primera versión pongamos el par de
electrones libres del azufre en la
posición ecuatorial justo aquí y también
en la posición ecuatorial tenemos dos
átomos de flúor por lo tanto tenemos un
flúor en posición axial hacia arriba y
otro flúor hacia abajo esta es una
posible estructura ahora para la otra
estructura pongamos el par de electrones
libres en la posición axial entonces
tenemos el azufre unido a tres átomos de
flúor en posición ecuatorial y después
tenemos un par de electrones libres en
posición axial y también otro átomo de
flúor
estas son las dos posibilidades entonces
recuerden que cuando tenemos un par de
electrones libres éstos ocupan más
espacio que los electrones que forman un
enlace por lo tanto repelen un poco más
analicemos cómo repelen a los otros
electrones en estas dos estructuras del
lado izquierdo tenemos un par de
electrones libres en la posición
ecuatorial y observen que al interactuar
con estos enlaces que se encuentran en
el mismo plano aquí tenemos un ángulo de
enlace de 120 grados
que no es tan importante en términos de
repulsión sin embargo también tenemos un
ángulo de 90 grados entre el par de
electrones libres y los electrones
formando este enlace en la posición
axial están alejados 90 grados habrá más
repulsión en esta interacción que en la
anterior entonces aquí tenemos una
repulsión fuerte pero también tenemos
otra con este enlace así que en este
ejemplo tenemos un par de electrones
libres a 90 grados de dos pares de
electrones que forman enlaces y eso
desestabiliza un poco pero vamos a
comparar esta estructura con la que
tenemos a la derecha aquí tenemos el par
de electrones libres en la posición
axial y observen que tenemos tres átomos
de flúor en la posición ecuatorial eso
significa que el par de electrones
libres
a 90 grados de todos estos tres enlaces
y eso provoca muchísima repulsión
entonces en el ejemplo de la derecha
tenemos tres interacciones de 90 grados
y en el ejemplo de la izquierda sólo
tenemos 2 y como nuestro objetivo es
disminuir la repulsión de electrones la
teoría de str nos ayuda a predecir que
esta es la estructura correcta en el
siguiente vídeo veremos que los
electrones libres se colocan en las
posiciones ecuatoriales de la geometría
y pirámide trigon al para minimizar la
repulsión entre los pares de electrones
entonces como la estructura de la
izquierda es mejor vamos a redibujar la
tenemos nuestro azufre unido a dos
átomos de flúor que se encuentran en el
plano y un par de electrones libres
también sobre el plano
estas son nuestras posiciones
ecuatoriales y en nuestras posiciones
axiales tenemos un flúor hacia arriba y
otro hacia abajo ahora el ángulo de
enlace entre estos dos átomos de flúor
esté aproximadamente 120 grados el
ángulo entre este flúor en posición
axial y este que se encuentra en
posición ecuatorial es de 90 grados y
finalmente el ángulo entre los átomos de
flúor en posición axial es de 180 grados
muy bien regresemos rápidamente a
nuestros pasos ya logramos predecir la
geometría de las nubes electrónicas y
encontramos la mejor estructura
finalmente hay que predecir la geometría
de la molécula y para eso vamos a
ignorar cualquier par de electrones
libres alrededor del átomo central
entonces si ignoramos el par de
electrones libres en el azul
y giramos la molécula ahora los átomos
de flúor axiales nos quedan
completamente horizontales y los dos
átomos de flúor ecuatoriales nos quedan
por acá esta es la geometría de balancín
geometría de balancín se le llama así
porque se parece a un balancín o sube y
baja en donde si un niño se sienta de
este lado hace que este lado baje y este
lado suba entonces esta es la geometría
de balancín en el siguiente vídeo
haremos otros dos ejemplos de moléculas
o iones que tengan cinco nubes
electrónicas